and my grandma's talking to you and then
I kept going like this and I'm like and
then so I pick him up and then I see his
eyes like like you know like rolling
back and his teeth all clenched in like
Grandma's I'm talking to you hello
[Music]
there's a bus driver in the state of
Wisconsin okay and she's pregnant of
course all right of course
makes sense I'm not shocked you're not
you're not shocked about this no so um
she's driving the bus right and she says
that um as she's driving she starts to
smell something burning
and then as he drives for another 15
minutes yeah first she's like well I
think it's another car and then she
drives for another seven hours I don't
think it's no she she was just driving
along small slipping burning she thinks
it's another car and then she starts to
drive more the smell and then all of a
sudden the smoke starts to get thicker
she sees smoke coming from the bus
so then she
gets on the radio and she she's like hey
I you know there's smoke in the bus like
it's hitting her in the face and eyes
and so she's just tearing up and she
could barely even talk into the radio
um and then she says her mommy instincts
kicked in really fast and she's like
okay [__] it I'm just gonna get these
kids off the bus myself and she
evacuated 37 students from a burning bus
holy [__] bus was actually burnt the bus
was burning does it say like what
happened what caused the bird yeah uh
it's just because the fire is not known
dang so she just smelt it and went
that's not far and he's doing skirt
skirt and then she just parked it oh
she's gonna be a great mom we're getting
out we're getting out yeah 37 kids so
she's like helping to carry them out and
[__] because it was all smoking so she
had to go back in it was all smoking
such she could barely even be on the
radio pull right she's
gone
amazing locations are like breathing in
the crazy fuse she basically was a
firefighter she was mommy Powers dude
that's gangster dude that is no that
kid's gonna be fine it was just one
Instinct yeah if it was like consistent
you know she was like smoking oh yeah
that's true she's doing it every day
yeah she's doing every day that kid
might be fine 37 imagine after she gets
the kids out she's all that was close
I need some box wine I can smash the
whole box right now I mean talk about
some [__] instincts do you guys think
you can pull that off I'm not dude okay
you already doubted yourself
dude look I [__] parked my bus and
run out go run kids kids ride and I
count them I'm gonna be like yeah 37
yeah yeah 37. I'm one of those guys
that's like
slow at the wrong times yeah like some
crazy [__] happens I'm like
what
oh yeah do something everybody do
something I'm still like processing is
this real yeah 13 more minutes just like
have you seen Geo do some mommy [__]
like like Mommy power [__] uh mommy
Powers oh you're talking about the
fabled zombie kicking superpower yeah
Mommy like can lift the [__] fridge
the first time taika had a seizure yeah
Mommy Mode what'd you do so taika had a
seizure uh this is when we even knew he
had seizures the very first time very
first time he comes up and he lays on me
he's like rocking back and forth and
then Grandma was telling him something
I'm like hey like Grandma's talking to
you like you gotta you gotta respond
when my grandma's talking to you and
then I kept going like this and I'm like
the [__] and then so I pick him up and
then I see his eyes like like you know
like rolling back and his teeth all
clenched and [__] you know Grandma's
[__] talking to you hello
so I don't know I don't know if he was
choking on something I don't know
seizures or whatever so I was like oh
[__] so I immediately uh yelled at
Grandma I'm like call 9-1-1 right now
the [__] that [__] got arthritis and
[__] so she's [__] like that [__]
and our [__] hands are all shaking in
my mind you know when things slow down
because it's like crazy I'm like [__]
it's three numbers but just uh okay
do it and I'm like so I'm like I'll grab
a grab Tiger's mouth on my [__] he
chokers out try to pry it open I'm
sticking I was like fishing for
something nothing was in his mouth and
as soon as I pulled my finger back out
Jaws clenched and then his lips started
turning blue I'm like [__] I gotta give
this [__] to CPR so I gave it to
him through the nose because his mouth
is clenched yeah so I was uh through the
nose protocol and then I was I put him
on I was doing the nose and then I'm
like go [__] tell Gio to come out
Jill's taking a shower so she she said
what the [__] going on like get the
[__] out here she comes out butt naked
soap shampoo everything and I'm like I
didn't say your mom [__] can't call
911 but I was like you call 9-1-1 she's
like what's happening so she calls um
and that's when I saw her like like I
think when she when like she knew was a
real real emergency there was no like oh
let me put on pajamas first or do
whatever you know it's just butt ass
naked with shampoo in her hair call it
9-1-1 I'm giving this
it was like and she was pretty much butt
naked the whole time trying to like get
her mom down uh she was like talking to
the the operator and tell the the
paramedics and firefighters came and
then she was like oh I'm naked yeah
totally [__] nude yeah just explaining
[__] like yeah I just saw him
is that hard for you because like you're
seeing what your son's going through but
yeah like my wife's getting me really
horny right now yeah
yeah
yeah that's a good question I like that
question good good question should I
like yeah fake some of these seizures
holy [__] dike is having another one
every time she gets in the shower every
time yeah yeah if this was a Hollywood
movie she would have shampoo like foam
right above her nipples yeah let Michael
Bay get a hold of this yeah a movie
written by a 13 year old boy
did the paramedics help them like gain
Consciousness or just over time he so we
didn't know what was happening yeah yeah
I was giving him the Heimlich maneuver
and it seemed like he was waking up like
it was helping but it wasn't it's just
seizures just don't last that long so
it's more correlation it was like oh
it's working it's working so I kept
going but it wasn't it's just like
seizures only last like 30 seconds so he
was like like kind of coming to anyways
ah and then the [__] paramedic that
comes is a stutterer oh yeah I [__]
hated this [__] because he comes
look at Chevelle
so what happened I explained the whole
thing to him I'm like cool so the he
goes and explains to the captain that's
there because he's like
I had a seizure and then like all of us
is like she's like hurry up like you can
fix them do something what do you do
like give him a shot or [__] some
like I don't know like what you do to
fix
and I'm like did the wrong word [__]
spit it out bro [__] but aren't you
kind of like I'm so glad to see
representation like for the southern
Community
[Laughter]
GS scores through the roof that's pretty
cool can you make this [__] like
the driver so he doesn't have to say
[__] Yeah put him behind the stairs why
is he the one taking the notes I know
what are you taking EMT class like they
train you on how to like be as specific
because you can and to deliver it so
that's why he was stuttering a little
bit he wanted to be as specific as he
could right well give him a chance if I
write seizure with seven s's I think it
makes the note even more money
he stutters with his notes with the
writing system
you know he gets paid by the hour right
he's trying to get that over time yeah
yeah maybe he was a fan of you yeah he's
like oh it's [__] yeah he's like it's
part of naked Geo
yeah you didn't think about all these
things yeah bro be more empathetic yeah
empathy yo yeah but that was that was
great that was like the first time I
think I saw like that [__] uh turn on
kitchen yeah oh yeah because usually
it's like like let's say I [__] what
they're like she's taking a shower I'm
like I just make it cold
yeah
I've known her a long time she's like
what the [__] is your problem yeah bro
that was like nothing mattered she just
came out it was like this is what's
happening and yeah just 100 focus on on
that situation you know like took the
phone number did that get you boned up
how mommy she was yeah so later on that
night
what happened yeah probably for sure
you weren't in the mood now well it's a
good thing you didn't just go
hello
my boy
he's like coming too and I just like
this was already putting coins on his
[__] eyes
burning burning incense
leaving the fruit bowl by the altar
Grim Reaper too early it was just a boy
to take me it's like it's not done yet
dude that's a man's response yeah 100
damn yeah that [__] was crazy but after
that there hasn't been anything anything
no thank God yeah so the next time he
had seizures it was like real chill yeah
well the next time was at school
um no the first no no no yeah then we
would go pick them up but it's like it's
like way more chill now because you kind
of you know what it is you know the deal
the first time it was like it could have
been anything you know like what the
[__] happened that he banged his head or
something my favorite is how you said he
faked it to like mess with you that's
the funniest story ever what a little
jerk he did yeah he cranked him no he
didn't yeah no he didn't it's his son so
yeah
and then so like after he faked it a
couple times like he'll still make it a
thing because we have to have his
medicine by 7 pm at night and sometimes
we'll forget like we're like after jiu
jitsu we go and eat and then it's like
oh [__] 6 30 we have to like we have to
rush home and get the medication so I'll
be driving home and he knows like he's
riding with me and I'm like we gotta go
get the medication the medication and in
the car he'll be like how many more
minutes that I'm like 10 minutes he goes
oh my arm
[Laughter]
yeah yeah show your dominance yeah you
know he'll never do it do it now do it
now so you're dominant start now start
now do it when you get home out of
context so he doesn't even know why yeah
yeah
what's that foreign
[Music]